the governor of texas is under pressure
this morning to stop the planned
execution of a woman named melissa lucio
back in 2008 she was found guilty in the
death of her two-year-old little girl
lucio's lawyers say the evidence shows
it was a tragic accident her supporters
include nearly half of the texas
legislature including members of both
parties and even some of the jurors who
convicted her lilia luciano has been
looking into this case
bobby alvarez carries the words of his
mom tattooed on his chest i always be
with you and here i'll always stay
and i decided to get it like right here
because you know it's close to my heart
but time is almost up for melissa lucio
and the cry to stop the clock is getting
louder
i don't want my mom to be executed the
mother of 14 children will be put to
death on april 27th accused of killing
her two-year-old daughter mariah it was
an accident if they go through it
they'll be killed in an innocent woman
bobby alvarez was seven when mariah died
he says mariah fell down a flight of
stairs and died two days later that's
what lucio told first responders and the
police but when the medical examiner saw
the toddler's body covered in bruises it
was ruled child abuse and investigators
zeroed in on lucio now are you a
cold-blooded killer or were you a
frustrated mother who just took it out
on her
for whatever reason
no
lucio who was pregnant with twins at the
time endured over five hours of
interrogation where she denied killing
mariah says vanessa potkins at the
innocence project over 100 times she
asserted her innocence they refused to
listen to her sending the clear message
that this interrogation wasn't going to
stop until she told the officers what
they wanted to hear and she did saying
she spanked the child but never
admitting to the use of deadly force
that demonstration sealed lucio's fate
why do you think she confessed her
so-called confession was the result of
highly coercive interrogation tactics
some of which are so coercive that
they're no longer used today experts on
false confessions who reviewed the tape
say she was especially vulnerable as a
victim of child sexual abuse and later
domestic violence developing defense
mechanisms child protective services
records show lucio was neglectful but
not violent against any of her children
but jurors didn't hear testimony from
any of lucio's kids tivon shardle is
part of lucio's current defense team and
says jurors were not given the full
picture there's been just a concerted
effort to keep this evidence from being
considered evidence that could have been
exculpatory oh it's definitely
exculpatory the medical examiner
concluded mariah died from a blow to her
head but today multiple expert
pathologists agree mariah could have
suffered a head injury from a fall
leading to a disorder that causes
extreme bruising it looks from the
outside like somebody has you know
gotten say punched it's very common to
be mistaken for abuse if you don't look
for the signs in 2019 the fifth u.s
circuit court of appeals ruled lucio had
been deprived of her constitutional
right to present a meaningful defense
and overturned her conviction but in
2021 the full court upheld her
conviction for procedural reasons a
technicality what would it mean to you
to have your mom back with you
everything um you know that's my mom
i even told her myself that i considered
her my best friend
sorry
now the power to save lucio lies in the
hands of texas republican governor greg
abbott the board of pardons and parole
and the current cameron county district
attorney whose office said in a
statement to cbs news a jury of lucio's
peers rendered to her a verdict we
cannot allow the rule of law to be
suspended and substituted by a court of
public opinion but at least four of
those jurors now agree lucio should get
a new trial given the new evidence and
testimony they didn't see she also has
the support of an unprecedented
bipartisan coalition of 87 texas
lawmakers as a conservative
republican myself who has long been a
supporter of the death penalty in the
most heinous cases i have never seen
i have never seen a more troubling case
than the case of melissa lucio as the
days tick down bobby is soaking up every
moment he has with his mother while
holding on to that small speck of hope
however even if lucy's death penalty is
commuted she still isn't going home
anytime soon do you envision a future
where your mom is out and hanging out
with you i do you know i shared my mom
that there's times where i do have
dreams about her and it's always like
folding clothes or you know just talking
you know it's never those extraordinary
dreams just those little moments for cbs
mornings i'm lilia luciano
seems to be a lot of reasonable doubt
race in that case and the fact that you
have bipartisan support and the jurors
is what gets me the jurors who convicted
her are now saying something right yeah
and the multiple expert pathologists who
agree that she could have hurt her head
falling downstairs